allez va les pattes moi ton pis aller
voir les boîtes moi ton qui l'a mené
l'attaqué comme la vie bande de vie
depuis longtemps que jésus a lui averti
travail malgré un prix pas dans les
cérémonies rituelles mais un moment là
fait le maloya moins avancés par rien
que ça ça compte toute manifestation
d'un essence le baptême le mayall la
communion
tout un défi lié tout pareil mais
monocyle avec les heures très différent
parce que musulmane effet pouvait-il et
en trois temps mon métier mon truc c'est
quatre temps cela fait 7 6,6 par rapport
à une moyenne à akoupé refrain même
balle que mitraille de six loups et des
bas mais ne la protège adc puisse
empêcher la sagesse actifry que de
gagner 5 mm qui l'a goûté tout témoin à
ces plantes et mes d'aujourd'hui la
réunion matp pas des femmes sont montées
mais quand même ça les jeunes n'étaient
pas pas été levées mais les comptables a
pris en main parce que mollet pas
d'apprendre à mieux disparaître la
minute en amont aux remplaçants
go live du maloya oui nenê peu partout
mais d'aucuns prévient typé mais la
souffrance n'a toujours pas ce que tout
le temps nous plaire ils n'ont connu
qu'un seul nous les soucis pour calmer
le souci jonathan beauté y en a une
bonne salade et l'énergie d'une
récompensé mais le mariage peut
disparaître il pas chez moi ici
noureddine malien n'avait paru merci à
sylvain comme ça mais je dirais qu'ils
montent dans tout le monde entier une
identité singulière du grath palmaria
l'écrivain peuple la souffrance d'un
peuple tout ça va pas ruiner secours le
beau gadin panama d'interpréter de
l'unesco c'est l'esprit de manuel ammann
en souffrance mais la famille d'abord
parce que les mots paumés cédé que moi
l'a fait il lui a red bull mais pâtit
festival métissé angoulême après dernier
aux comédies faut absolument aller plus
loin disputé un p6000 une nation de même
d'un pays ami
la peine maximale et puis moi pas c'est
indépendant verges à steve horizon
conseil régional il dit si le tiède à
moins il fait pas plus loin c'est de
préparer la fête nécessaire sma - simon
shaw l'ati stream et au delà des
fragments d'âme bataille des postes le
le niveau elle naquit hatton
mais est monde il peut paraître sans
musique
il faut lui manifestent partout ça me
demande le peuple aregno le tout
ensemble et sa crasse est ici à la
réunion qu'en métropole
je ne veux rien ni la grâce de dieu le
cas et des samples fêter le grand
cabaret de regagner pas le débattement
mich est la bienvenue
mama papa médecin de famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guimauve heures